Entonces consultó a una boina verde sobre la forma más respetuosa de hacerlo,
y decidió arrodillarse durante el himno nacional.
Perdió su contrato con los 49ers,
todos los propietarios de la NFL lo rechazaron,
fue criticado por millones
e incluso el presidente de EE. UU. decidió insultarlo.
Pueden pasar décadas antes de que respeten a Colin Kaepernick
como merece por su coraje,
por eso nuestro equipo decidió hacerlo.
Ahora cualquiera que pase por Trump Tower puede ver a Colin Kaepernick arrodillarse
en realidad aumentada,
y no hay nada en contra que puedan hacer al respecto.
(Risas)
La representación es importante.
Serena Williams demostró al mundo
que una chica negra de Compton puede dominar un deporte
que tradicionalmente se juega en exclusivos clubes.
Celebrémosla ahora.
Jackie Robinson
rompió la barrera del color
y capacitó a muchos atletas negros para jugar en las Grandes Ligas de Béisbol.
Vamos a tomar este monumento de él y ponerlo en Ebbets Field
para que cualquiera pueda verlo batir por las cercas
en Ebbets Field en Brooklyn.
Con realidad aumentada, tenemos el poder
de contar historias en espacios públicos que deben ser contadas.
Los logros de personas como Frida Kahlo, Audre Lorde,
Toussaint Louverture,
Señora CJ Walker,
deberían ser de conocimiento común.
Nuestra visión es un "Pokémon Go" para una historia contextualizada.
La realidad aumentada también se puede utilizar como una herramienta
para apoyar a las organizaciones que luchan contra la opresión sistémica.
En 2019 lanzaremos nuestra aplicación gratuita para teléfonos inteligentes
con monumentos y contenido de realidad aumentada.
Podrán tomar su móvil y sostenerlo sobre cualquier billete de un dólar
y ver una escena en realidad aumentada
que ilustra la injusticia de las fianzas en efectivo.
Luego pueden hacer clic en la pantalla
y ser dirigidos a la página de donaciones de The Bail Project,
un fondo que recauda dinero para personas que no pueden pagar la fianza.
Con realidad aumentada,
nosotros las personas, tenemos el poder
para resaltar las narrativas de los oprimidos
cuando las instituciones se niegan a hacerlo.
Podemos usar esta herramienta para resaltar las implicaciones sistémicas
de borrar la historia de alguien.
Y más concretamente,
podemos usar esta tecnología como una forma de apoyar iniciativas
que luchan contra el racismo sistémico.
Con AR, tenemos el poder de reimaginar un mundo
que prioriza la justicia sobre la opresión.
Gracias.
(Aplausos y vítores)